what is going on everybody and welcome
to an image and text-based game LED
entirely by an AI so an AI is generating
the imagery the text the situations the
options that you can choose from and
then what happens from there it's all AI
based and the imagery here is generated
from openai's Dolly and the text is chat
GPT via the API now you could actually
have in the back end different types of
models if you wanted so if you wanted to
use some other diffuser model for the
imagery that's totally fine and if you
wanted to use some other text generative
model for the text generation that's
also fine the idea here is really just
it was an idea I had obviously this the
concept of a sort of interactive Journey
you know text-based Journey or game or
whatever through GPT models that's not
new I haven't seen anybody tie in you
know the image generation but one that's
not really that advanced and two I'm
sure somebody has thought of this before
instead it's just trying I'm trying to
like get my mind to wrap around this new
possibility and capability of web
applications and that just software in
general I think there's so much
more that we can do with software now
that we have models that are these sort
of kind of natural language
understanding and generative models and
even you know because they're so General
we can take these very general models
and restrict them to a much more narrow
application and these models are still
extremely powerful and actually more
powerful than if you just try to train
some narrow model on that task and in
fact there are I I know at least there's
a hundred thousand dollar Bounty for uh
showing any task that if you have this
larger more generalized model
any task where if you actually had a
more narrow model you if it if that if
you can find some instance where it
performs better in that way like some
sort of type of task
um people are looking for this because
we're finding as we make bigger and
bigger models uh in much more General
and general models that are either even
multimodal models as you restrict go
back down to restrict those models to do
some sort of task they're actually way
better so anyways uh without further Ado
this is the journey this is just one
specific example of the journey every
single Journey that you would take here
is entirely unique in its own way and
the options that you get everything is
unique and no two Journeys would ever be
alike same thing with the images in a
specific Journey we first encounter a
mischievous fairy which we attempt but
fail to capture then we get paths to
choose from consequences from those
paths in this case wolves which we
choose to scare off with our sheer
bravery then we meet and speak a bit to
a ghost we accept and we are given a
riddle which we promptly solve due to
how our my extreme intelligence as we
leave we encounter a dragon which we
probably won't beat this time in a
physical match and I'm done testing my
luck with pure bravery so I opt to use
magic to put it to sleep I find some
villagers and they offer me a horse to
get home
and comically well chat gbt does give me
the option at this point to go ahead and
just like steal that horse even though
they offered it to me for free
um I did opt to just take them up on
their offer and I ride that horse home
to complete my journey and again every
time it will be something completely
different in in my experience so far
with just this exact pre-prompt and all
that I do find the there's a Common
Thread and theme that I keep coming back
to which is either finding your way back
home or finding your way to a new home
um that said you are completely in
control of what prompting you want to
use in the themes and maybe even you can
even you know encourage it to generate a
certain type of story so maybe you want
it to be more of a strategy based or
more of a riddle based or space themed
or what whatever you want
um you you can pre-prompt your way into
it and again I just I present this
purely as a way to hopefully get people
to start thinking more into the future
about how will we not only make that
software right
um I even in this project it's very AI
based in terms of how I developed it but
then also the software the end result
software can also be heavily heavily AI
based in the back end so anyways uh
without further Ado let's jump in so to
begin I'm going to start with some code
that you've seen before if you've
already done the basic chat GPT API uh
tutorial video that I put out last but
even if this is your first sighting of
openai first of all you will need an
account and it's billing to be set up
and all that or you can just kind of
watch again you can replace the back end
with anything the reason I went with
chat GPT is one I just wanted to Ticker
with it see how much it would follow my
instructions how well it would adhere to
them and then two it is just simply well
now that I'm filming this gpd4 just came
out but but it's really expensive like
prohibitively expensive in my opinion uh
at least for a task like this it has
other very very interesting implications
especially given the 32 000 context or
33 000 token sized context but yeah I
don't think that's actually out yet but
anyways digress so open import open Ai
and then we will go ahead and set the
key which I just am now realizing I
haven't saved one moment okay and in my
case I'm going to go open AI dot API key
is going to be equal to open and I saved
mine in the key dot text probably the
superior way to do this would be to set
an environment variable
um but I'm not just I'm just not going
to do that so so we set the key and now
I will Define chat and again this is
going to be I think identical or at
least very very close to what you've
seen before if you followed mine uh and
in fact it looks like chat gbt has
memorized it already I will be putting
uh all the code uh in this tutorial in
the description also the previous one
that's available on GitHub as well uh
there are things I just refuse to type
out uh like the pre-prompt I'll explain
what the pre-prompt is but it's just a
very long prompt I'll read it out but no
reason to type it out
um so let me make sure this is exactly
what I want so we do want to take a
message history as input we will default
to the role user again that is kind of
what we did before
um the API is just going to take
essentially a list of these like dicks
and you will pass for the context the
history context basically the chat
context you're going to pass a bunch of
these
um content that's just going to be the
text and then the role whether that was
the user the assistant which is chat gbt
or system which at the moment I don't
find much use of a system but maybe in
the future or maybe people will learn
what is the use what's a really good use
case for system but anyways continuing
on completion open AI dot chat
completion so if this doesn't work for
you you need to upgrade your open AI
installation
we're going to use the GPT 3.5 turbo
model that is the chat GPT model
essentially and at least at the time of
my recording that's 0301 and as at some
point it will be upgrading to o302 that
may change some of the behavior so keep
that in mind maybe they'll allow a way
to use the older version I don't know I
know there's a way to use the new the
upcoming version but it's still I think
changing so I didn't really want to mess
with it and then messages like I said
this is going to be a list of these
dictionaries of you know in other order
um of the messages so reply content this
is just the actual text so once you get
a completion it's going to come back
it's going to have a whole bunch of
stuff first you're going to have a bunch
of choices to choose from we're just
going to go with the very first choice
we're going to grab the message message
stuff and then we're going to grab the
content from that which is going to be
just that text and then we return just
that text as well as the new history
that we will later be able to append to
and so on so so far that's all code that
I've already shown before so it's kind
of convenient that it went ahead and
already just like pre-populated that for
me I don't see much benefit in typing
all that out all over again so then I'm
going to now copy and paste the uh the
pre-prompt that I'm going to use now let
me also turn on
uh word wrap
okay so this pre-prompt is just the
first pre-prompt I thought to try I've
had at least a decent experience setting
pre-prompt so I kind of know what to
look out for
um but again this was the very first I
tried there are ways that I'm sure we
could make this prompt even better and
produce even cooler uh scenarios and
results
um but this is the one so I start off by
with the role of user saying you are an
interactive Story game bot that proposes
some hypothetical Fantastical situation
where the user needs to pick from two to
four so already you could you could add
more options you could also describe the
situation in a different way if you
wanted to pick from two to four options
that you provide and not only could you
make that a more narrow thing you could
actually say you can make it more
generalized if you wanted so if you
wanted a lot more variability in the
situations that come up anyway I picked
from two to four options that you
provide once the user picks one of those
options you will then State what happens
next and present new options and this
then repeats if you understand say okay
and then begin when I say begin when you
present story and the options present
just the story and start immediately
with the story no further commentary and
then options like option one option two
Etc so as you can see we're gonna we're
trying to leave the story somewhat you
know open for openai uh chat GPT to
think about and come up with but then we
do want structured answers after it
presents the story so some of you
probably already see why why I'm doing
it that way and then what we're going to
wind up doing to turn this into a web
app but next
rather than leaving it open for chat gbt
to come up with something else I just I
force chat GPT essentially to say okay I
understand begin when you are ready so
now it's just expecting a begin from me
so to issue that begin all we would need
to do is we could just say reply uh
reply content
message history chat begin okay you're a
wizard so we will just say begin
uh and then we will now the story let's
say begins so now I'm going to say four
um in range I don't really want to do
five I'm just going to stop at three I
think you'll get the idea at three I
assume
so
um I think basically so like when the
pay so this this will happen on page
load so when someone first visits that
page what do we want to show essentially
it would be this so imagine that's your
your get request you'll see what I mean
in a second but so we'll have already
acquired that information so let's go
ahead and print uh reply content
eventually we'll turn it into a web app
but I just want to show a basic form
just so you have an idea what's going on
and then so we've got reply content now
we're going to say next input is going
to be equal to input enter your response
that's fine
um and then this will repeat so the idea
here is to First make sure this works as
we're expecting so let me go ahead and
open a terminal GPD Journey Great Python
I think it's three on here GPT Journey
so we're waiting for a response from the
API uh so we have here two options in
this case so it just says great I wish
it didn't say great uh it shouldn't have
done that that would be a mistake that
would be something I would want to try
to massage the pre-prompt so that it
does not do that I we tried I tried to
say don't tell me anything else but we
might need to phrase that in different
way welcome to the world of magic and
mystery you've discovered a mysterious
doorway in the woods the door isn't is
old and Rusty with some strange uh or
with strange markings etched into its
surface as you approach the door creaks
open and a voice Whispers from the other
side so we have the option now to either
enter the doorway and explore or we can
leave the strange door and continue on
your journey presumably go somewhere
else but the idea here is I could say
option one and the hope is that the AI
is going to continue the story based on
us having chosen option one sure enough
we do uh and
uh this
this is interesting I I have personally
that's that's curious of this the first
time I've ever seen it propose option 1A
1B 1C head towards the college explore
the forest for Q you choose to leave the
strange drawer and continue on your
journey I'm actually not
I have not calculated for this too so
this is a good example of you know again
we really need more structure and at
least in my experience I've done
probably a hundred of these Journeys
I've never seen this and and of the
journeys that I've done I've you know
gone through many options I've actually
never seen it propose a 1a1b1c
uh
crazy anyway
um
I think I think my logic would still
handle for this but that's that's very
interesting anyway so we can continue
I'm going to choose option two option
two
I actually now this this will be in the
context forever so it'll probably
continue doing stuff like that that's so
funny
uh live demos okay who who loves them so
um anyway regardless of that strangeness
um option two 1c1 what is happening
that's so crazy
um I'm gonna pretend that's not going on
and we're going to precede the the root
but that's so funny
um
I for everything I can think of this
will still continue to work the way that
I've you know planned it but that's
that is funny okay so you continue to
potentiate the feeling that you might
have missed out on something special
oh gosh okay so it's at least you you
get the idea you're getting you you're
presented with a story then you're
presented with options you pick those
options and the story evolves based on
those options that you've chosen so okay
so we'll come back here and I think what
I'm actually gonna do
um I'll save this because we're gonna
copy pasta probably but otherwise I'm
gonna get rid of this and now we're just
going to do the web app aspects now
again comically enough uh for the web
app uh the way I started this web app
was actually I presented what I was
trying to do to chat EBT and I had Chad
gbt uh create the sort of scaffolding or
skeleton application for me and again I
just I I really um I don't want to gloss
over the fact of of how uh code
development is changing before our eyes
again you know yes we're making this AIA
AI based game in the showing off chat
gbt but also it's like I just can't help
but recognize how much AI has already
just infiltrated my development process
to the point where I I really do I
prefer using chat GPT and yes not
everything's right but you can go back
and forth and get it to get at least to
a point where you're pretty happy and
then you make the tweaks
um I don't know it's very it's very
interesting to to see what's happening
with AI in specifically coding and
obviously everywhere but coding for sure
obviously for me that's that's kind of
where I see it impacting so much so fast
um anyways continuing on while I still
have a job first what I'm going to do is
we'll come to the very tippity tap and
let's go ahead and uh from flask we're
going to import a flask render template
uh request and session
um okay so once we have those I'm also
going to import a re import re for
regular Expressions we're going to use
that to pull out basically these options
so we're going to once we get this just
because obviously Jan gbt doesn't know
you probably could though like part of
what I've been thinking about with chat
gbt is like you could tell chat GPT that
not only is an assistant it's a
web-based assistant and please always
return to me a full HTML page of what
you know whatever your response to me is
and that's kind of one of the other
projects I plan to try to do is it it
really could talk as you know talk to me
in HTML or talk HTML to me or something
like that will be the name all right and
um I really think that like you could
get crazy Fancy with this stuff so you
probably wouldn't even if you wanted to
you could probably come up with some
sort of prompt that you wouldn't even
need to do what I'm about to do but
anyways continuing on so regular
Expressions uh let's also go ahead and
app equals flat yes sir thank you app
dot uh secret key secret key equals yes
big secret thank you
um and then while we're at it um the
other thing I want to grab from openai
is the image generation or uh you know
the dealing with the image API uh we can
well we can type it out let's do Define
get image
um
I will pass prompt
so that will be the prompt and then
we're going to use the openai
uh API for Dolly so we are going to
encase this in a try and accept a very
general except exception exception as e
we're not even going to handle for
accept exceptions e we're not even going
to
um
it took me way too long to realize for
what I had typed
um we actually don't want to print e my
bad and instead we're going to say image
URL equals and I'm going to copy pasta
this so we're going to attempt to query
the dolly API but if the dolly API
detects uh an image that it thinks it's
on say for whatever reason it's going to
fail so we want to be able to handle for
that I didn't find chat gbt to fail on
me too often but the image generation I
did have that fail I mean at least a few
times especially on this like
Fantastical Journey if you get into a
fight with some monster or whatever like
it the I I think it's a little
overbearing I wish I could see the
images it's trying to blow out on me but
such is life so what we're going to do
is we're going to say resp in this case
response is equal to openai dot image
dot create
and in this case we will pass prompt we
will say we just want one image and then
size we're going to say in this case
will be 512 by 512 there's 256 by 256
512 by 25 and 10 24 by 1024. I did not
find response time to vary enough to
make a difference I just 512 by 5 12 is
a good size so that's what I went with
all of them take about five seconds or
so to generate an image
um and we'll I'll try to remember to
talk a little bit more about response
time and how we you could get around it
if you if you wanted to like if you
really wanted to make this put this into
production and have people play it or
use it or as you're thinking forward
into like how might software like this
really truly function if it wasn't like
a game and it was instead you know some
end user product there are ways that you
could you could fix this but anyways
continuing on response uh and then image
URL is going to be equal to response DOT
first you'll get data we'll go with zero
with one and then we will say dot URL
the API does not actually return to you
an image it returns to you a link to
that image I don't know how long that
link is good for but it's good enough
for our application now you might need
to in production you might it might be a
case where you'd want to save that
locally but yeah we just want to display
it so if it fails I'm going to just
display an image that says the image
failed or something like that I can't
remember exactly what I made for that
image but I remember needing it so uh so
that's how we will get the image from
the dolly API that's all we have to do
here is for the chat API or chat jbt and
now we are ready to actually build our
application so I'm going to come down
here and
um
yeah I'm going to leave that just for
copy pasta uh reasons later and we are
going to begin so we're going to say at
app Root this will be our home page and
I want to pass methods will be actually
get and post I didn't see if it actually
suggested that to me methods equals
thank you sir
okay so that's our app Root and then we
will Define our index and in here uh
what we're going to do is first we're
going to start with I'm going to start
with the page title so this will be both
the page title and then the title
[Music]
um
in HTML basically so the tab title I
suppose I would call it so we'll call it
GPD Journey it was close to picking the
right title
and then we're going to start with
initializing the button uh button States
and the button messages so you'll see
what I'm using those for shortly but
so button messages will be an empty
dictionary and button States will be
also an empty dictionary then we will
begin with request. method I always like
to go in order so I'm going to start
actually with get so if it is a get
request the only time we should see that
is when the user first loads that page
essentially so when they're first
visiting what is step one that must
happen well we are going to start by
setting the session
and in this case we're going to start by
setting that message history and that is
going to equal this message history
however I'm actually going to Define it
in here now so I'm going to go bloop
like that and
you do have to make that noise when you
do it so make sure you do that if you're
following along uh I think we're good
there so that sets our message history
to start with and I think every uh I
can't decide if I want to leave word
wrap on or not I don't know it kind of
bothers me but maybe I'll leave it on
once we have that what we're going to do
is now we're going to message history
equals session and then message history
so now that that's saved to session
we're going to pull that from the
session we're going to modify this
variable as we're working and then at
the end we'll reset it to that
cool so message history done reply
content message history Eagles chat and
in this case we are going to issue the
begin and cool roll will not be
assistant it will actually be user that
is the default so I'm actually going to
go ahead and just do that
um cool so reply content is going to
contain both the uh kind of story text
and then and the option so what we
really want to do is we just for now or
because we're going to make buttons out
of the options especially I don't want
the options in the text we want those to
take on the form of a button so instead
we're going to say is we're going to say
text equals reply content that's correct
but we're actually going to dot split
and let's see if it I don't think it
could possibly know what we want to
split by so we're going to split by it's
close option
um
option one and again if it does as one a
one that stuff we're in trouble but
that's okay so we'll split my optional
actually it would always start with at
least this so
let's put it like that and grab the zero
with so that will be just the text next
we're going
uh
yep
this is why I love copilot because this
is exactly what I freaking wanted to do
next yes thank you
so essentially to find the options that
we wish to use we are going to use a
regular expression to find all instances
of option some number followed by some
text this will give us a list of the
options that we have to choose from
because it is going to be dynamic it's
two to four again you're you're free to
say 2 to 10 or 2 to 15. I mean you can
have a lot of fun with this generating
lots of options you could even allow the
user access to a text box I didn't do
that because I just feel like that opens
the door to too much like it'd be too
easy to like hack the journey I guess
and I I feel like it would be less fun
but I really don't know and again this
was just this is a really quick project
that I whip together
um just trying to see like is this
functional does this idea work and then
just just trying to get used to like
working with all these this this new
kind of software and this new capability
of of applications
um I'm still wrapping my head around it
so text and options uh great we've got
that now we want to do is we are going
to uh create a dictionary for the uh
buttons and their options all that so
what we're going to say is for uh
stop
at least this is not quite what I wanted
but I'm every time
every time I think about
um
I mean let me write this out first and
then I'll I'll say what I was thinking
um so button messages and then this will
be in this case an F string button I so
yeah so so crazy every time uh copilot
suggests something different than what I
have in mind it always like makes me
stop and think like hmm am I actually
doing what I want or is there a better
way like it always like makes me feel
like I'm probably doing something wrong
um anyway but once I started this it
actually did correctly predict what I
was going for it's so crazy it is so
crazy
um it's so fun to like point out all the
flaws of these GPT style models but at
the end of the day that like the doors
that are now open are just it's just
crazy it's mind-blowing to me
um okay so that is that's what I want
that's all I want for that Loop next
we're going to save four button name in
button messages we're going to say this
is close to what I wanted but not quite
we're just going to initialize them as
false so we're just saying hey no button
has been pressed
okay that's our get request if we had
the template already we could actually
test it and run it I don't have it yet
and I think this is actually simple
enough all we're doing we're
pre-prompting we're on the page load
we're actually going to go ahead and
query the chat GPT model this means the
initial page load will take a few
seconds again at the end I will do my
best to remember to tell you my various
ideas on how this could actually be like
Lightning Fast
um but for now we'll just we'll leave
that so what it's going to do is it's
going to begin it's going to get that
text presumably it will be passed you
will see later it grabs that text
um and then we also grab the options
which we're going to convert to buttons
but we you know we have this in a
variable so once you have this in a
variable and you pass it to an HTML
template you just do the double curly
braces boom you've got your variable in
there this we will iterate through with
a for Loop and ginger templating easy
enough and format it as a button boom
done easy so
that will load awesome that's actually
all uh all I want to do I believe
sausage
did we ever
um
I think while we could do this
um I'm actually going to do this just at
the end regardless of whether or not it
was a get or a post so I don't it's
copilot is correct and thinking that we
want to do that but I'm actually going
to we'll do that at the end so
um so if it's a request a get request I
think we're set yeah so now what I'm
going to say is we're going to Define
two starting things we're going to say
message equals none and we're going to
say button name equals none uh then
we're going to begin the post request
thank you Copilot
it's just so crazy how good copilot is
um I actually don't I'm not going to use
those just yet so we're going to open by
setting grabbing the message history
from that session which I do want
um and I do
that's okay message history equals
session I wish you could like tell
co-pilot like I just want that first
line there might be a shortcut for that
it'd be nice
um so we've got our message history and
then we're going to do button messages
equal session button messages yes that
is exactly what I wanted now button name
stop well how does it know that that's
what I want to do I don't know I think
this is valid uh someone comment below
if that's valid but I I've always done
it form dot get that looks that looks to
me like it would probably work but I
don't know form.get button and actually
it's not button
I got lured into that button name
um okay button name
cool uh and then what we're going to do
is now we're going to set that's the one
that got pressed so we want to go ahead
and add uh set that to true and so we'll
say button States
but name equals true yes correct so then
we're going to grab the message that's
associated with that button so that's
going to be button messages dot get I so
again I think that actually would work
but I'm going to do a DOT get just in
case I'm going to say button name
someone not only comment below if that
if the other method works if like if one
is better than the other for some reason
that I am unaware of
so so we have our button name we've got
our message yes we are now ready to
query the chat GPT API uh we do want
reply content message history we will
pass the message which is from that
button and the message history great
so
um yep that's I think that's everything
we want text yes sir that is what we
want so again we're just we're just
splitting at option one we want
everything above option one that will
hopefully be the story text that we want
to display in like paragraph form then
we're going to grab our options again
it's that same regular expression again
we probably could have like a function
or something else so we don't have the
exact same code as above but for now
this is just a proof of concept
and that is all I ever developed so
um now what we're ready to do is we've
got text we've got our options now again
we're going to reset
um and in fact I already started typing
but yeah so
copilot is just so good so copilot wants
to do this and this is almost exactly
what I wanted to do
um and in fact
yes that is actually accurate
um and then let's see for button name in
button messages
um
button messages uh buttons am I am i r d
of this I was using dot keys and
actually that probably didn't come from
me that probably came from chat GPT
um
I think that's a little redundant I
don't really know that we need that in
the grand scheme of things that's
probably that's not going to change
anything what we're waiting what we're
spending the most time on waiting for is
the response anyways but I believe
that's redundant
um again it's been chat GPD has been
coding for me so I I don't even know how
to code anymore
um so so this probably
it might work the problem is I think
really we need to throw in a button
messages in an empty dictionary here
because if we are presented initially
with four options we'd get four messages
and then if here we only had two we
wouldn't we would have more messages and
I I'm trying to think if that would
actually matter in the end I'm not
really sure it would
um but it seems wrong so I'm going to go
ahead and clear that out
beyond that
um we're done
so I'm going to come down here and we
are going to now reset our session
message history and the button messages
could we are done
it's so close to understanding
everything I want that's probably all
accurate index.html that's fine we're
going to return title equals title text
equals text button messages button
States button name I don't know that we
need button name let me just tab that
and accept what it suggested let me
check my code
yeah I don't we don't need button name
we can pass it I don't think we needed
that let me just I'll just delete it
because I I'm curious but I don't think
I need that but also we don't have our
image and I feel like the image makes
makes it way more interesting I really
have enjoyed the images so image URL is
going to be equal to get image and we're
in this case going to pass text now I've
I considered I thought it would either
that would work you know being very lazy
and just literally passing the entire
situation you know current situation I
also thought maybe it would just work
best to do like the last sentence so
split this into sentences and then just
go with the last sentence to generate
your image
um I I personally have found just
passing the entire entire text has
worked really well so that's what I'm
going to do I'm just going to pass the
full text
so that gives us our image and all we
want to do now is we're going to say
image underscore URL equals uh image
underscore URL I put a space there I
don't really think we want that it's
kind of annoying uh
[Music]
I believe we are good so then all we
would want to do at this point is if
really you're gonna maybe type this out
of all the things thank you
um I think on this port I think on this
machine I'd be fine on Port 5000 the
default one but I'm gonna set it 5001
and
uh we're good the only thing we're
missing now is the
index.html so GPT Journey we're gonna
make a new folder we're going to call it
templates we're going to come into here
and I'm going to touch a index.html
I'm going to minimize that out of the
way and we are going to open it with vs
code and here we are in our index.html I
am not going to write this out line by
line with you on video I think that's a
waste of everyone's time I'm going to
copy and paste
all we have here again this was uh
generated completely by chat GPT for me
I did not write this code I don't think
I wrote any of this code
um
I'm trying to think I don't yeah I did
not modify this at all I just told chat
gbt what I wanted I showed it I showed
it my I just passed in basically get
journey.pi I said generate me an
index.html that makes the choices a
button like that was it and then I asked
it to add style for me because it
started off without any style at all it
made me pick or told me some options to
choose from I just told it to choose and
that's it I mean that's that's it
um I didn't write this so
uh so yeah this is what it presented for
us
uh the title uh is that title
um and then it also shows the title and
text so this will be like your tab title
and then this is the actual title and
text
uh we will show the image itself again
that image from the dolly API is just a
URL so we're just displaying it super
simple if it fails for whatever reason
we're just going to display the URL from
python program.net that has that it just
says like image failed alt text we could
later add text to that I don't see any
benefit to that this page will never get
indexed anyways
but at a later date if you are using
this for other means you may actually
want to save that alt text and you might
want to make the page a static page or
save it in some way
um yep paragraph text we just paste the
text and then we will iterate over these
buttons
um so button name and message and
buttons and we just simply make those
buttons
that's it
um and then later if that if this is the
the button that actually got clicked we
show the message and that's that's it so
um
yeah pretty basic loading in the
JavaScript for bootstrap there's nothing
more to see here so we're gonna go ahead
and save that now what I want to do is
um
and in fact actually
now that I'm thinking about it this this
is redundant uh because this is going to
post immediately upon clicking the
button this will never show up at the
time it did show up um when I first
started without actually the post
request because I developed this HTML
page uh prior to
um having a post request created so
um
I'm just going to comment that out I
don't think that actually has a use
anymore but just in case I've I'm
derping at the moment which is totally
possible again I don't I don't write
code anymore
okay save cool uh yeah let's go ahead
and run it let's see what happens
let's see what happens
GPT journey.pi boom
okay no immediate error that's nice
we're gonna open that
pull that down
so initially the load is a little long
uh it's uh chat ebt's maybe a two to
three second response time and then
um Dolly is about a five to six second
response time so adding it all up you
know you can you can get to the 10
second Mark it's a little it's a little
harsh
but let's go ahead and test this real
quick and then I'll talk about my ideas
for how you could actually speed this up
so you find yourself in a dense Force
completely lost as you're walking around
you try to find your way back you hear
strange noise coming from behind you you
turn around to see a giant talking
mushroom staring back at you
so run away from the mushroom as fast as
you can I might get up and search Jason
you never know ignore the mushroom and
continue walking around we'll run away
approach the mushroom let's try to
communicate make sure our post is
working and in fact let me
this real quick
make sure that we don't see an error
okay you cautiously approach the
mushroom and try to strike up a
conversation the mushroom responds in
perfect English and tells you that it's
a magical mushroom that can grant wishes
however before it can grant you wish you
first must pass its test uh oh a live
test for me on oh yikes I just think we
should refuse that test what the test
entails before making a decision hell
yeah
hmm
laughs
the mushroom tells you that the test
involves a series of riddles that you
must solve if you answer all of them
correctly it will grant your wish
agree to take the test
let's get to these riddles I find when
it presents you the options to answer
your riddle
um it feels as though it's much easier
than if you just had to input text the
mushroom nods and starts asking the
first riddle what has a heart
but doesn't beat
an artichoke like
um you get the idea I don't think I'm
going to progress through this entire
Journey like I said this one does tend
to as you do your journey it does tend
to
um what begins I'm sorry I have to I
have to read it what begins with t ends
with t and has t in it
what tangent t
[Laughter]
ense
what begins with t
ends with t and has t in it I don't know
tangent
say you don't know I wonder what would
happen if you said you don't know
because I mean t has t in it but it
doesn't end in t
what runs around the whole yard without
moving
offense a dog on a leash I almost want
to like answer the wrong thing and say
it doesn't know
I'm gonna say a dog on a leash and get
it wrong and just see what happens
I'm just curious
I never failed these riddles I've this
is like the second time I've seen these
these riddles
the mushroom nuts I don't think a dog
was the right answer right it should
have been like a fence right I'd have to
maybe I'll go back and see my wrong
answer but
what is always in front of you but can't
be seen the future
air your nose
I'm gonna say your nose
let's see if it nods with approval
I think no matter what we were going to
win that riddle that's interesting uh
grants your wish as for the ability to
fly oh my gosh I have a lifetime
supplied for a magical object I want to
fly I mean that's that's my dream okay
so how could we further improve this so
what I was thinking about was you know
this is a it's a pretty good amount of
time in between
um
in between these responses because of
the the time it takes to generate the
image because of the time it takes to
generate the text a couple things to
think about here first of all the so the
capability of these models I think is
you know like is really what we're
trying to test at you know at the outset
of these models it's seeing like okay
these things that historically have this
has never been a possibility for us to
just write up a quick app like this in a
day and have this sort of functionality
this is crazy
um it the response time first of all
these models the hardware will improve
the infrastructure for companies that
provide apis like open AI that will
improve the response times will go up so
or go down I guess anyways improve
um so you know into the future three to
five years let's say this functionality
what we're doing here can be instant so
that's number one so first just like all
the things that you're thinking of
especially if you're trying to like
start businesses on this kind of stuff
or think about it in terms of your own
company or your Enterprise whatever
where you
you want to start thinking like okay
well like let's figure out what's
possible today and maybe it's not as
fast as we want it to be but in three to
five years it will be and then who knows
what else is going to be possible but we
gotta start thinking about things in in
this way this sort of like Dynamic
software way that really we've just
we've just never seen or had the ability
to have tools like this at our disposal
and again at least what I'm tinkering
with now in all you know to to develop
this app and work on this app and I
spent many too many hours like playing
in this app
um I think I spent like three dollars in
API query so it's super cheap so it's
already cheap it's just not maybe not as
fast as you would want but if you did
want to make it faster there are things
that you could do so first of all you
could pre-load the next prompt so for
the next viewer or user you could have
already pre-loaded that begin right and
had one ready to go and you could just
be constantly preloading those prompts
so everyone gets a unique one that's
never been seen before but just preload
them so you could pre-load them and just
start by injecting that into getting the
responses but when you pre-load that as
soon as you have that you know what the
options are so in this case
we could have pre-loaded a prompt we
could pre you could pre-load however
many steps into the future you want to
go and by the time like the response
time this is a pretty short one but a
lot of them are kind of long and
especially once you read all of this
text and then all the option text you've
probably exhausted five to ten seconds
so you could have you could just be one
step ahead of everybody it would cost
you in this case about four times more
money for the query so rather than
spending three dollars in a day of
development or three dollars you know on
you know for a user to use it for you
know say all day or for a few times or
whatever
um it might be a little more expensive
so 12 or something like that and again
the that is very twelve dollars would be
very expensive for like a day's use of
some software uh so then that like that
decreases your capability of like what
who might find this useful but uh as
time goes on again this this level of
performance will get cheaper over time
there's no question this gets cheaper as
time goes on and then if you did if you
could change the back end of all these
models and actually do all the
pre-processing on like CPU and Ram or
your own local hardware or whatever to
reduce costs so again there's what I
what I really want to show and think
about is more like what what's possible
yes to kind of proof a concept today but
imagine what will be possible in three
to five years it's going to be insane so
um so anyway you could pre-process so
you could pre-process that prompt you
could pre-process the response and
imagery for each of these options as
well so that you could go two steps and
you could just keep doing that as far
out the tree as you want to go obviously
each step you go out it is going to like
times four sometimes it you know you
only have two options so it's a little
cheaper
um but you could you could do that as
far out as you want to go so anyway
um yeah that's at least one way that
this could be done and you could do that
in like um you know in separate
processes or something and not have one
result waiting on the other results but
anyway
uh pretty cool it's a it was a fun app I
enjoyed playing with it if you have an
open AI key I encourage you to download
it and kind of play with the journeys
they're they're pretty fun to be honest
they're kind of Addicting to go through
I do wish the response time was a little
quicker but I actually didn't really
mind the response time when I was
tinkering with it but
um yeah you'll find a lot of the stories
at least with this prompt too do like I
said earlier kind of Follow that sort of
similar trajectory of like you're lost
on this journey find your way home find
a new home find new like a new set of
people to hang out with so in that in
that example that I showed when we found
the villagers one of the other Journeys
I went on was uh I ended up finding some
people and then I ended up just like
living out with them basically
um they pretty much always end in a
Wholesome Way which was also curious
um but again through pre-prompting you
could probably get them
um you you could tweak these stories
however you wanted so anyways lots of
stuff to play with if you've got like
suggestions on how to improve that do
feel free to leave them below also if
you want to learn more about neural
networks and how they work you know what
I'm going to say neural networks from
scratch book at nnfs.io for how to
create and train and test use neural
networks completely from scratch in
Python no third-party libraries we do
wind up using numpy just to make things
easier but only after we show how it's
done in true raw python so if you want
to learn more about neural networks and
how they work definitely check out the
book at
nnfs.io otherwise I will see you all in
another video and again if you want the
code A Links will be in the description
for the full code so you can just
download it and play with it and I look
forward to seeing if anybody comes up
with cool cool uh cool examples cool web
apps and stuff definitely share them
down below if you do
um and like I said or like something
like the talk HTML to me or something I
think I just man there's so many doors
that are open now uh that we just kind
of have to figure out what makes good
prompts what what types of structure do
we need to have uh to make things work
and all that so it's it's really
exciting it's a really exciting time to
be playing with models like this so
anyways that's all for now thanks for
watching and I will see you all in
another video